after two divorces and being a single
mother living paycheck to paycheck
michelle boyle had an aha moment that
created a blueprint to a better
lifestyle and she created a
tiny house village resort to empower
other women to be independent and enjoy
the little things in life
take a look at this i'm michelle boyle
after my second divorce
my life imploded i moved to oregon with
my two kids and after about a dozen
years of being a single mom
i realized as they headed out to college
i'd set them up for their future but not
myself at all
so i moved into a tiny house the whole
idea at the time was
to reduce my overall expenses so that i
could actually start saving
for my retirement then in 2018 i decided
if i opened up a tiny house village i
could actually not only reduce my
expenses with a tiny house but i could
also increase my income with a tiny
house
originally my tiny house village was
just one house of course my tiny perch
now we actually have five
i had the pleasure of staying in
michelle's tiny house village
last may 2020 i booked a weekend
spent it in a tiny house it was my first
time i loved every minute of it
i was so inspired by my time at
michelle's that i
am in the process of having my own tiny
house built
so it's been a full circle year and i
want to say thank you michelle for
inspiring me to follow my dreams and
creating a life that i love
our message to divorced moms like me is
that there
is indeed life after divorce you can
build a big beautiful life for yourself
and share it with others please welcome
michelle boyle
hi michelle hi i can't believe i'm here
okay i am so obsessed with you i have
so many questions but i want to start
out with
okay so you went and explored other tiny
villages
is this correct yeah oh absolutely
so what i want to know is what was your
takeaway from them
my really my takeaway is is there's
not a lot that we all actually need we
have
big houses with rooms that we never go
into
and stuff that we never use and so my
takeaway
was that there's so much that we have
that we don't actually
need and so that was a that was a big
moment and your
overhead used to be sixteen hundred
dollars and went down to
two hundred dollars yeah my rent
alone was sixteen hundred dollars before
i moved into my tiny
and that didn't even include utilities
so now
my space rent for my house plus my
utilities plus
everything is yeah less than a few
hundred bucks a month okay
and then also why did you decide to
create this village
which if women are dealing with divorce
and want to downsize and find a
community
what was that impetus for you
to get that started because you did this
for yourself but you're really doing it
for other people as well
yeah i mean i tiny house living changed
my life
so dramatically so the number one thing
that i set out to do with the tiny house
village was really to inspire other
people
to step outside their comfort zone to
try on tiny for a weekend
and see what it feels like um some of my
guests
come and they go and they actually build
a tiny house for themselves
some of them are like no way not for me
but you don't know until you try
well i think you're right and now i know
these tiny houses can have some design
challenges is that true oh my god
tiny houses huge design challenge
so you have to design them intentionally
not by the square foot but by the square
inch and not just design challenges but
also
placement challenges
i think people should think that way no
matter what
[Music]
you